mesdames et messieurs bonjour donc avec
Florent
bouer nous tenons tout d'abord à vous
remercier pour votre présence à
l'occasion de la présentation du rapport
de la commission d'enquête concernant
les groupesuscules violents et les
violen au sein des
manifestations avec ce rapport d'enquête
que nous vous présentons ce matin
prennent fin les travaux de notre
commission qui aura œuvré pendant 6 mois
avec patience et méthodes pour tenter
d'éclairer le Parlement et à travers lui
les Français sur les violences qui ont
entaché tout au long du printemps 2023
le débat public autour de grands enjeux
aussi bien sociaux
qu'environnementaux le sujet est
d'importance pour l'ensemble de la
nation et la procédure là une nouvelle
fois montrée alors que les commissions
d'enquête procèdent désormais pour leur
grande majorité de ce que l'on appelle
le droit de tirage dont bénéficie euh
pour leur grande dont bénéficient pardon
les groupes politiques celle-ci a connu
une genèse un petit peu
différente pour rappel c'est dans
l'hémicycle et plus précisément le 10
mai 2023 à l'issue d'un débat de
plusieurs heures que les députés ont
décidé de sa création par 200 voix 204
voix pour et 47 voix contre à partir de
là les 30 membres appelés à y prendre
part recevaient une mission essentielle
simple dans son principe mais il faut
bien le dire délicate dans ces
modalités établir comprendre et
expliquer ce qui entre le 16 mars et le
3 mai 2023 avait conduit à des violences
contre les personnes et contre les biens
lors de manifestations et de
rassemblement déclaré spontané voire
dans certains cas interdit l'État de
droit appelle un équilibre subtil entre
l'exercice des droits fondamentaux d'une
part la protection des personnes et des
biens d'autre part la la rédaction
initiale de la résolution prévoyait
d'enquêter je permets de de reprendre
l'intitulé sur la structuration le
financement l'organisation des des
groupuscules et la conduite des
manifestations illicites violentes
c'était une tonalité qui relevait
quasiment de l'investigation judiciaire
fort à propos en commission des lois
puis devant l'Assemblée nationale notre
rapporteur Florent bouer s'est attaché à
amender cet objet ainsi il est devenu et
je cite documenter les actes commis par
les auteurs de violence en manifestation
certes mais dans toutes les
manifestations et rassemblement et
explorer également le déroulement des
événements en cause pour interroger
aussi bien les succès que les carences
ou encore les manquements du maintien de
l'ordre c'est dans ce contexte que les
commissaires m'ont fait l'honneur lors
de la réunion constitutive qui a eu lieu
le 24 mai de cette année de me désigner
à la présidence de la commission
d'enquête j'ai tâché au cours de ces 6
mois de diriger ses travaux dans un
esprit d'impartialité et
d'objectivité chaque sensibilité a pu
s'exprimer non seulement parmi les
députés membres de la commission mais
également dans la société française dont
les institutions et les associations les
observatoires les observateurs de tous
les horizons ont été conviés à déposer
devant notre commission les suggestions
d'audition présentées par les différents
groupes politiques ont toutes été
satisfaites et si les compte-rendus
témoignent et vous pouvez regarder le
tome 2 qui comporte plus de de 600 pages
ces compte-rendus témoignent d'échang
parfois vif il reflète fidèlement une
confrontation des regards qui est le
cœur de la démocratie comme de la
fonction parlementaire la commission
d'enquête a beaucoup travaillé elle a
procédé àprès d'une quarantaine
d'auditions ici à l'Assemblée nationale
représentant à ce titre Plus de 50
heures d'échange une délégation du
bureau bureau a par ailleurs effectué
deux déplacements au cours de de cette
période déplacement d'une part dans les
département de la Gironde et d'autre
part des Deux Sèvres il s'agissait à
travers cela de pouvoir interroger les
acteurs locaux et pour acquérir
évidemment une connaissance approfondie
des lieux sur lesquels des
confrontations avaient pu éclater durant
cette période concerné par la commission
d'enquête alors le rapport d'enquête qui
vous est présenté ce matin est le fruit
de emble de ces travaux en croisant les
récits et les relations des événements
le rapporteur parvient à établir des
faits et à restituer les différents
points de vue pour dépeindre un tableau
le plus fidèlement possible des heures
du printemps dernier les éléments qu'il
présente avec rigueur et objectivité
nourriront évidemment le débat qui va
suivre ne serait-ce qu'au travers de ce
que vous allez vous-même relayer dans
vos articles et dans la presse bien sûr
chacun bâtira à à partir de ces
prémisses des démonstrations différentes
en lien avec sa sensibilité politique
mais au moins la base de réflexion
pourra-t-elle constituer je l'espère
enfin nous l'espérons un socle commun le
rapporteur a ensuite formulé des
conclusions ces conclusions sont
évidemment personnelles ainsi que des
préconisations les membres de la
commission qui l'ont
souhaité j'en fais d'ailleurs partie on
fait de même et les contributions
des uns et des autres sont annexés au
rapport là encore telles sont les règles
du jeu démocratique que cette commission
d'enquête a scrupuleusement respecté
tout au long des travaux les débats ont
été riches instructifs parfois sensibles
et à l'occasion aussi tranchés mais
toujours respectueux ouvert et
pluraliste les désaccords de fond n'ont
jamais fait obstacle à la discussion et
tous les commissairirees sur tous les
bancs ont fait avancer la réflexion
collective qu'il me soit évidemment
permis ce matin d'adresser une des
remerciements plus particuliers au
rapporteur Florent bouer à la fois pour
la confiance réciproque qui a pu
s'installer puisque comme vous le savez
les commissions d'enquête et bien il y a
aussi d'une part le rapporteur
représentait la la majorité et et moi
l'opposition euh je pense que nous avons
pu créer en fait un climat de confiance
euh qui nous a animé en permanence dans
l'exercice de nos prérogatives
respectives un regret toutefois perdure
la commission d'enquête a donné la
parole à tous le plus souvent elle a
offert une tribune à ceux qui
souhaitaient d'ailleurs témoigner de
leurs expériences et de leur conviction
à de rares occasions elle a dû user des
pouvoirs que lui confère l'ordonnance du
17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires pour convoquer ses
interlocuteurs et dissiper de VI voie
les prévention nourrie à l'encontre de
ces visés supposés les auditions en
question ont été finalement profitables
à tous pourtant malgré la convocation
formelle de ses porte-paroles pront à
s'exprimer face aux médias mais
visiblement suspicieux devant
l'institution parlementaire une
organisation a obstinément refusé de
paraître il s'agit des soulèvements de
la terre ils ont pourtant joué un rôle
capital dans les événements de sain
Soline qu'il appartenait à la commission
d'enquête de documenter d'ailleurs deux
autres organisations qui avaient appelé
à la manifestation
ell se sont présentés devant la
commission là il y a
évidemment une difficulté en dépit de
relance multiple et de plusieurs
discussions infructueuses sur les
conditions d'une audition celle-ci n'a
pas pu avoir lieu ce refus de concourir
à l'exercice démocratique dans des
conditions de publicité transparentes
avec les élus de tout bord est
évidemment dommageable à tous à la
commission d'enquête privée d'événements
d'éléments utiles sur les événements
aux convictions privées d'coo à la
République dont les principes les plus
évidents ont ainsi été sapés pour cette
raison et comme le droit le commande
j'ai requis du procureur de la
République de Paris l'exercice de
poursuite pénale sur le fondement de
l'article 6 de cette fameuse ordonnance
du 17 novembre
1958 donc poursuite à l'encontre des
porte-parole qui avaient été convoqué
puisque même si on nous parle d'un
collectif à partir du moment où il y a
des porte-paroles et bien leur
responsabilité en tant que porte-parole
est engagée la loi protège l'information
des députés car une Assemblée nationale
méprisée devant laquelle on
comparaîtrait simplement selon son bon
vouloir serait un bien pauvre garant des
libertés démocratiques les droits du
Parlement doivent être défendus j'ai
donc pris ma part dans les fonctions qui
étaient les miennes en tant que
président de cette commission d'enquête
tel est l'esprit qui a présidé aux
travaux de cette commission d'enquête et
qui a concouru je l'espère au soutien
Casas unanime exprimé par ses membres à
l'adoption du présent rapport puisqu'il
a été adopté à l'unanimité moins une
voix contre je forme le vœux qu'il
alimente à son tour les réflexions des
différentes institutions pour que les
manifestations et les rassemblements à
venir au cours desquells les Français
usent de leur liberté fondamentale et
prennent légitimement part au choix
politiqu de la nation se déroulent dans
le respect de l'ordre public d'une part
et de l'État de droit d'autre part pour
conclure je tiens à dire que j'adère
très largement au rapport qui va vous
être présenté maintenant par monsieur le
rapporteur comme lui je déplore la
banalisation de la violence sa
légitimation par sa non condamnation
catégorique par certains acteurs le
dévoiement du concept de désobéissance
civile à des fins violentes alors que ce
concept justement s'encre
fondamentalement dans la nonviolence le
fait que certains campus deviennent
hélas des bases arrières de la violence
et en enfin que le concept de collectif
soit parfois utilisé par certains pour
échapper au contrôle de l'État et au
respect de l'État de droit concernant
les recommandations pour la partie
législative nous allons là aussi
travailler tous les deux à une
proposition de loi commune parce que
nous avons là les bases d'un travail qui
qui mérite d'être poursuivi je vous
remercie pour votre attention et sans
tarder je vais passer la parole à
Monsieur le Rapporteur avant que tous
deux nous ne nous prêtions aussi à cet
échange avec vous sous forme de
questions-réponse donc merci à vous et
je passe la parole à notre
rapporteur merci Monsieur le le
Président je me joins à vos à vos propos
concernant la la qualité de nos travaux
votre capacité à avoir conduit les les
débats à la fois dans la bienveillance
le sérieux l'écoute de toutes les
sensibilités qui composent notre
assemblée c'est le principe même d'une
d'une commission d'enquête vous me
permettrez
d'aller cette fois-ci au au cœur du du
rapport pour vous donner quelques
quelques éléments avant de répondre à
vos questions plusieurs questions se
posai avant de députer nos travaux l'une
d'entre elles était de mieux comprendre
comment sont organisés structurer
financer les groupuscules violents et
les individus violents qui les composent
l'une d'entre elles aussi était de
savoir s'il y a des lien formel
organique avec des structures partisanes
existantes avec le cas échéant des
structures syndicales existantes à ces
questions dans le rapport nous répondons
à l'issue de 6 mois de travail de façon
assez clair me semble-t-il il n'y a pas
de lien organique il n'y a pas de lien
formel entre des groupuscules violents
issus d'horizons très différents de
l'ultra gauche par exemple des ultra
jeunes qui sont des catégories que nous
ciblons et que nous déclivons en tout
cas dans le rapport et euh des
structures partisanes traditionnelles il
n'y a pas de lien formel il n'y a pas de
lien organique en revanche il y a
parfois une forme de glissement vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président une
forme de légitimation une forme de
banalisation de la violence l'absence de
lien ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas
des passerell et c'est sans doute d'une
des caractéristiques de notre temps de
notre époque avec je ne reviendrai pas
sur des propos que vous connaz sous
connaissez tous des formes parfois
d'incitation de légitimation je le
répète à la viol parfis même à la
violence la plus brutale pas de lien
organique et formel mais parfois il y a
une base militante qui peut se
reconnaître dans des actions violentes
des modes opératoire violents alors même
que la structure à laquelle ils
appartiennent ne la pratique évidemment
pas je pense monsieur le Président il
vous en souvient par exemple au syndicat
cgtnergie ce n'est pas la CGT qui a
appelé à commettre violence nous l'avons
constaté évidemment la violence est
rejetée par sa secrétaire générale en
revanche le syndicat CGT ennergie par
exemple à Bordeaux a commis des coupures
d'électricité sur des services publics
vulnérables sans que cela n'it
manifestement suscité un très fort émoir
y compris parfois dans le milieu
syndical et là nous voyons qu'une base
militante considère que les modes
d'action traditionnels ne sont plus
adaptés et qu'il faut aller vers des
modes de confrontation beaucoup plus
direct en l'occurrence jusqu'à mettre en
péril le cas échéant des personnes qui
étaient hospitalisé au centre au centre
hospitalier de Bordeaux dans le centre
ville donc pas de lien formel pas de
lien organique mais des passerelles un
contexte qui donne parfois le sentiment
d'un glissement c'est le mot que
j'emploie dans le rapport et je le
prends reprend d'ailleurs de l'autrice
Monica Sabolo dans la vie clandestine un
roman qu'elle a publié en 2022 comme
vous le savez peut-être le deuxième
point qui nous intéressait tout
particulièrement c'est c'est quoi cette
galaxie d'une certaine façon des
groupescul des individus violents
comment ça comment elle est composé d'où
vient-elle quels sont les types de
profil je ne pourrais pas devant vous
rentrer dans tous les détails mais nous
avons je pense monsieur le Président
documenté à l'aide des indications qui
nous étaient données y compris
d'ailleurs de la part des services de
renseignement nous avons documenté la
typologie des différents groupe et
individus correspondant il y a bien sûr
les groupes traditionnels
ultra gauche ils sont euh ils
appartiennent à un mouvement ancien qui
prend parfois ses sources dans les
années 70 même si bien sûr il a
considérablement muté il y a aussi les
individus qui sont sortis de la séquence
des gilets jaunes sans déboucher
institutionnels politique et qui sont
allés vers des formes d'action ultra
violentes il y a aussi des phénomènes
d'opportunisme il y a aussi des
phénomènes de solidarisation sur les
lieux de manifestation ou de
rassemblement il y a bien sûr aussi des
phénomènes de délinquence venant s'agéer
à ces manifestations et ses
rassemblements mais nous avons toujours
veiller dans le rapport et à l'occasion
de nos travaux de distinguer bien sûr
les manifestants les organisateurs des
manifestations celles et ceux qui sont
dans la contestation sociale
revendicative tout à fait normal ça
s'appelle tout simplement à la fois la
liberté fondamentale de manifester et la
démocratie et des individus qui
notamment dans les précortèges en marge
des manifestations en marge des
manifestations ont l'intention
d'affronter directement les forces de
l'ordre les symboles de l'État les
symboles d'un certain nombre de causes
pour lesquelles ils lutent par exemple
la question de l'ultra capapitalisme on
attaque les banques on attaque de
grandes enseignes commerciales par
exemple internationales
cette petite galaxie de l'activisme
violent je pense qu'elle
s'élargit sont très élargie ça surface
sé lgie et elle gagne en particulier sur
des marges liées notamment à la cause
environnementale et nous faisons la
distinction entre le combat écologique
porté par un certain nombre à la fois de
personnes de groupes partisans voilà qui
s'inscrit dans le débat des démocratique
à l'évidence et puis une forme de dérive
d'activisme violent nous allons avoir
des roulement de tambour sur la
cérémonie du 11 novembre qui est décalée
je vous préviens tout de suite et donc
il y a notamment une cause
environnementale à laquelle se greve un
certain nombre d'activistes violents sur
ce plan je voudrais être très clair sur
les événements de saintsine en
particulier qui se singularis dans la
séquence temporell que nous avons
étudié pour noter d'abord la respons
ilité absolument écrasante des
organisateurs du mouvement de Saint
Soline au mois de mars dernier
dans les affrontements que nous avons
connu à l'égard en particulier bien sûr
des forces de l'ordre responsabilité
écrasante refus total et absolu de toute
forme de contact avec l'autorité
administrative la
préfecture refus de déclarer la
manifestation refus d'ailleurs un
recours administratif contre
l'interdiction de la manifestation la
même façon puis refus aussi de discuter
de planifier de travailler à la
stratégie de secours pour celles et ceux
qui le cas échéant sur place pourrait
être blessé ou simplement être souffrant
dans les circonstances d'une
manifestation cette responsabilité elle
est écrasante je n'en conclus pas et ce
fut parfois une divergence avec certains
membres de la commission d'enquête que
quand on é él national ou quand on est
élu local il ne faut pas aller
participer à des manifestations
interdites ça n'est pas mon point de vue
je ne donne pas cette leçon de morale
dans les rapports dans le rapport en
revanche il me semble absolument
indispensable que lorsqu'on exerce des
responsabilités politiques notamment on
puisse mesurer les risques dans une
manifestation un rassemblement interdit
qui on qui ontcorté de très nombreux en
raison précisément du refus des
organisateurs de toute forme
d'organisation et il y avait dans les
jours qui ont précédé la manifestation
de saintsoline une volonté de monter en
tension une stratégie assumée de
confrontation de la part des forces de
l'ordre qui ne pouvait inévitablement
que débouger déboucher sur des actes
violent et c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé et nous avons constaté sur place
nous y sommes nous y sommes rendus qu'on
regarde la topographie des lieux au
regard aussi de la stratégie défensive
des forces de l'ordre pour qu'il y ait
confrontation avec les forces de l'ordre
il fallait avoir l'intention de la
confrontation et il fallait aller au
contact et au contact des forces de
l'ordre et donc je ne jette pas la
pierre à des élus qui se rendraient dans
les manifestations interdites peut-être
que dans d'autres circonstances dans
d'autres temps peut-être dans le futur
aurais-je moi l'occasion d'aller
manifester dans des manifestations
interdites peut-être avec l'écharpe plus
blanc rouge pas impossible ça dépend de
notre situation politique le moment ven
mais y aller en connaissant les risques
y aller en sachant que les organisateurs
en particulier font tout pour qu'il y
ait une montée en tension dans une
stratégie d'affrontement
conscientisée théorisée à l'égard des
forces de l'ordre ça effectivement c'est
une faute et c'est un acte de nature
irresponsable j'en viens
maintenant au débat autour du maintien
de l'ordre nous n'avons pas souhaité
l'esquiver nous avons même au contraire
souhaitait rentrer de plein pied dans ce
sujet en modifiant l'intitulé vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président de la
commission d'enquête pour ne pas viser
la conduite des manifestations mais leur
déroulement je souhaitais que nous
puissions aborder la question du
maintien de l'ordre parce que c'est un
débat aujourd'hui extrêmement clivant
parfois à front renversé c'est le moins
que l'on puisse dire avec des attaques
qui sont à mes yeux à nos yeux monsieur
le Président insupportables à l'égard
des forces de l'ordre en particulier
mais nous avons regardé
comment fonctionner le maintien de
l'ordre en France dans un contexte de
montée en puissance de l'activisme
violent de ce point de vue nous en
tirons quelques leçons la
première c'est que si nous voulons faire
baisser
d'incran le débat parfois la mise en
cause directe inacceptable vis-à-vis des
forces de l'ordre Alvor il faut sans
doute que l'État la puissance publique
joue peut-être plus à plein la le jeu de
la
transparence c'est ainsi que je propose
dans le rapport que l'on puisse créer
des statut d'observateur indépendant
aujourd'hui il y a des
observateurs sont-ils indépendants je
n'en suis pas toujours sûr parfois oui
mais parfois non parfois certains des
observateurs que nous avons reçu
auditionnés appartiennent à des
mouvements qui appellent eux-mêmes à
manifester leur point de vue consiste
d'ailleurs à regarder plutôt le
comportement des forces de l'ordre cela
nous a systématiquement été rapporté de
façon très claire plutôt que de regarder
la situation dans son ensemble comment
se comporte d'un côté les individus
violents quels étaient leur mode
opératoire quelle a été la réponse
proportionné des forces de l'ordre pour
d'une certaine façon en finir avec ce
débat je crois qu'il faut que nous
puissions mettre en place des
observateurs indépendants de la même
façon que sans doute faut-il en France
se doter d'un contrôle externe du
maintien de l'ordre beaucoup plus
puissant il existe le contrôle externe
c'est le défonur des droits en France il
y a les inspections internes ça c'est
leôle interne je parle duôle externe par
le B d'une autorité administrative
indépendante je souhaite que la
Défenseur des droits puisse obtenir des
pouvoirs supplémentaires notamment de
sais aussi des moyens matériels qui
permet de donner tous les éléments au
débat démocratique y compris à la
représentation nationale sur les
constats qu'elle pourrait établir
concernant le maintien de l'ordre nous
donnons aussi instme d'indication il y a
un vrai problème au moment de la
dispersion des précortèges où se situent
les difficultés encore une fois pas dans
les manifestations dispersion beaucoup
de manifestants de bonne foi
d'organisations syndicales nous disent
il y a une difficulté pour distinguer
les manifestants de bonne foi biennent
contester c'est bien leur droit bien sûr
en France tel ou tel projet de loi ou
initiative politique et puis comment les
distinguer des individus violents à ce
moment précis sans doute qu'il faut
faire un effort de communication sur les
lieux de manifestation des panneaux de
signalisation question de des sommations
qui ne sont pas audibles de la part des
manifestants là on rejoint des
considérations pratiques qui ne sont pas
législatives et qui sont de l'ordre de
la modification pratique d'un certain
nombre d'éléments tenant à
l'opérationnalité du maintien de l'ordre
je disais observateur je disais contrôle
externe Défenseur des droits je disis
journaliste également un certain nombre
de vos confrères nous ont signalé que
dans bien des cas ils étaient parfois
eux-mêmes
l'objet de d'attaque de violence ou
simplement d'insulte de la part
d'individu quel qu'il soit dans le cadre
des rassemblements et qu'il y avait
aussi parfois des difficultés dans la
relation avec les forces de l'ordre et
de ce point de vue je pense que nous
avons été très clair monsieur le
Président sur ce point il faut passer
d'une certaine façon de l'intention aux
actes le Conseil d'État dans une
décision de 2001 avait imposé que le
schéma national des mati de l'ordre
clarifie la situation des journalistes
en situation de manifestation il y a un
certain nombre d'éléments opérationnels
qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas toujours pas
toujours observés là de ce point de vue
il faut qu'il y ait une
clarification je propose dans l'une des
recommand
les voies et moyens pour y
parvenir et puis dernier point et je ne
serai pas plus
long il concerne évidemment la meilleure
façon de
lutter efficacement dans la
proportionnalité dans le respect aussi
de nos libertés et de l'État de droit
contre les individus violents et les
grouuscules violents de ce point de vue
plusieurs mesures sont
proposées qui consistent à renforcer
notre modèle de maintien de l'ordre et
nos outils
penaux sur la question des forces
intermédiaires des moyens
intermédiaires les armes qui sont
utilisées par les forces de l'ordre nous
souhaitons qu'il y ait des évaluations
beaucoup plus fréquentes pour en mesurer
l'impact possible sur les manifestants
mais aussi mieux formmer à leur usage au
sein des forces de l'ordre il y a
parfois des faiblesses de ce point de
vue nous souhaitons aussi que ces moyens
intermédiaires soi
renforcés je pense en particulier aux
canons à haut cela paraît trit concret
Salé en effet mais c'est un moyen de
mise en distance assez peu utilisé en
France plus utilisé dans le nord de
l'Europe il y a sans doute des efforts
pour se doter en équipement de cette
nature notamment lorsque les théâtres de
manifestation le permettent sain Soline
su été compliqué dans les manifestations
parisiennes contre la réforme des
retraites su été beaucoup plus simple
donc à la fois mieux les évaluer parce
qu'il y a des débats parce qu'il y a
aussi des manifestants blessés et puis
renforcer les capacités des forces de
l'ordre parce qu'il y a des nécessités
d'adaptation je pense à la question des
drones en particulier je pense que et je
propose que leur usage puisse être
élargi déployé il permet à la fois de
regarder le déroulement des
manifestations il permet d'identifier
les zones où les difficultés se
déroulent et il permet aussi par exemple
contrairement à ce qui s'est passé à
Soline qu'il n'y ait pas des stratégies
de
dissimulation engagé vis-à-vis des
forces de l'ordre qui par exemple au
même moment recevait des messages qui
étaient des messages en fait de
dilatoires pour masquer la réalité du
terrain en indiquant qu'il y avait un
blessé ici alors qu'il n'y était pas
qu'il y avait des troubles en tel
endroit ce n'était pas de cas et les
forces de l'ordre avaient les plus
grandes difficultés pour pouvoir
comprendre la réalité de ce qui se
passait en en en temps réel et donc les
drones sont une solution et je pense que
il faut étendre leur usage le volet
pénal qui sera support monsieur le
Président d'une proposition de loi que
nous déposerons dans les prochains
jours il y a sans doute nécessité de
renforcer le cadre touchant aux
interdictions de manifester aujourd'hui
cela nous a été communiqué par
l'autorité judiciaire je pense notamment
à la procureur de la République de de
Paris il y a des angles morts sur
lesquels nous on apporter des réponses
il n'est pas possible lorsqu'une
personne est en situation de violation
de l'interdiction de manifester qu'elle
a donc dès à présent été
condamnée pour des faits qui peuvent
être grav il n'est pas possible lorsque
il y a soupçon que cette personne est en
train de violer l'interdiction de
manifester parce qu'elle est par exemple
à proximité d'une manifestation de la
retenir sous forme donc de rétention
pour une durée
de quelques heures de façon à vérifier
pourquoi elle est dans tel ou tel lieu
et de s'assurer qu'elle ne veut pas le
cas échéant revenir sur la manifestation
pour commettre des actes violents je
souhaite aussi que l'on puisse élargir
le champ des infractions qui donnent
lieu à une peine complémentaire
d'interdiction de
manifester par exemple lors de la
participation à des attroupements qui
est un levier pénal très important dans
notre dispositif juridique la
participation à desatroupements après
sommation de la même façon que je pense
qu'il faut que nous allions vers le
caractère obligatoire de la peine
complémentaire d'interdiction de
manifester à l'image des interdictions
de stade qui a été adopté notamment en
vue des Jeux olympiques de 2024 pour les
infractions les plus graves je dis bien
pour les infractions les plus graves par
exemple les violences commises
concrètement de même que par exemple
pour le port d'armes donc là il s'agit
comme l'ancien Premier ministre Bernard
casenuve l'a dit devant la commission
d'enquête d'utiliser et nous a incité à
le faire d'ailleurs d'utiliser à plein
les outils juridiques les réponses
pénales permant permettant de prévenir
la commission d'un certain nombre
d'actes violents parce que les individus
concernés sont parfois connus ont
parfois été condamnés et il ne faut à
leur égard agir avec aucune forme de
naïveté l'obligation de pointage
également des personnes condamnées à une
interdiction de de manifester et puis
j'en viens au point qui rebondit le plus
d'une certaine façon sur l'actualité
concernant la dissolution des
associations et des
groupements
nos auditions démontre qu'il y a
aujourd'hui une très grande difficulté
pour la puissance publique de
documenter le lien entre le comportement
d'un certain nombre d'individus et la
structure à laquelle ils appartiennent
qui est pourtant une réforme que nous
avions introduite lors de la loi de
lutte dite contre le
séparatisme de ce point de vue nous
souhaitons modifier le code de sécurité
intérieure et son article
L212-1 sur ce point
précis de façon à ce que ne soit pas
simplement visé les provocations à des
jissements violents mais des
provocations directes ou indirectes de
façon à ce que nous puissions élargir le
champ qui permettra ensuite à nos
services de renseignement à nos forces
de l'ordre de documenter les violences
qui ont été commises et de documenter
aussi de façon plus précise le lien en
tout cas le fait que l'appartenance à
une structure telle que par exemple le
soulèvement de la terre et des actes qui
auraient été commis puissent d'une
certaine façon matcher contrairement à
aux indications que le Conseil d'État a
pu donner dans sa décision récente voilà
je ne veux pas être beaucoup plus long
nous n'avons pas cherché à travers cette
commission d'enquête
à forcément rebondir sur des textes de
circonstances nous allons être très
précis dans les propositions que nous
ferons dans la proposition de loi qui
sera déposée dans quelques jours nous
avons à la fois voulu apporter des
réponses extrêmement concrètes le
marquage chimique par exemple marquage
chimique est évoqué comme solution
parfois rêvé pour identifier les
individus violents des manifestants nous
considérons après examen après audition
que il y a des possibilités de transfert
de la matière chimique pulvérisé sur des
personnes qui ne sont pas liées aux
violences que il n'y a pas aujourd'hui
de cadre juridique et je demande dans le
rapport qu'il est par exemple un
moratoire sur le marquage chimique qui
ne semble pas être une solution
acceptable donc des propositions très
concrètes très opérationnel qui relèvent
même pas du pouvoir réglementaire qui
sont de l'ordre de la pratique des
dispositions qui relèvent plus
précisément du pouvoir réglementaire
statut d'observateur contrôle externe du
Défenseur des droits je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il y ait besoin d'intervenir par la
loi et puis un volet pénal plus
répressif que nous affirmons parce qu'il
y a nécessité de fermeté absolue à
l'égard des individus violent qui porte
atteinte à la fois la liberté de
manifester et bien sûr à l'ordre public
des propositions législatives que nous
pensons être ciblés très cerné pour
tenter d'apporter des réponses à des
angles morts parfois à des législative
qui ont pu apparaître au cours de ces
derniers mois de ces dernières années
voilà pardon d'avoir été un peu long
concernant la présentation des éléments
principaux de ce
rapport merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur alors avant de vous passer
évidemment la parole simplement je
voudrais aussi en en profiter pour
remercier je pense que je le fais au nom
de l'ensemble des des membres de de de
la commission les administrateurs euh
sous la responsabilité de de Monsieur
Souplet vraiment les remercier parce que
vous le savez pour qu'une commission
d'enquête fonctionne il y a aussi une
équipe et et et celle-ci a
merveilleusement bien fonctionné donc un
grand merci à eux aussi pour pour leur
engagement à nos côtés et à partir de là
je vous passe la parole je sais pas qui
souhaite démarrer
oui je vous en prie
madame j'ai trois tout petites questions
la première ce ser sur l'évaluation
des moyen forces intermédiaires don vous
avez parlé comment on évalue moyen for
intermédiaire vous avez parlé du marcage
chimqueat j'imagine sur des armes vous
avez peut-être aussi une idée de la
manière de l'évaluer sur les
interdictions de manifester vous avez
parlé d'interdiction judiciaire je
demand ce que vous pensiez un commission
administrative qui on souité par
exemple et qui n'ont pas été mis en uvre
jusqu'à présent constitutionnel et enfin
sur la proposition loi vous allez
présenter est-ce que
vous avez parlé du volet pénal est-ce
que c'est vol pénal
l'essentiel je vais je vais je vais
commencer par par la dernière ça
permettra déjà de euh en fait si vous
regardez le le rapport il y a 36
recommandations sur les
36 quelques-unes de ces recommandations
sont de nature législative et concernent
plus particulièrement le code pénal ce
sont les les les recommandations à
partir de de la numéro 21 donc c'est 21
22 23 24 25 et puis ensuite la 26 sur le
le code de le code de de de la sécurité
intérieure donc voilà donc ce sont ces
ces recommandations là qui puis ensuite
il a encore 27 28 enfin vous vous
regarderez euh bon maintenant le le
travail encore une fois il va il va se
poursuivre avant de de déposer le texte
il faut qu'on aille un petit peu plus
loin il nous importait dans un premier
temps de respecter le délai pour le
rendu du rapport de la commission mais
on va maintenant aller dans dans le
détail de de ces mesures sur la la
deuxième question que vous posiez je
vais laisser évidemment aussi monsieur
le rapporteur donner donner son son
orientation sur cette question
aujourd'hui comme il l'a indiqué ce qui
pose problème c'est que nous avons d'ors
et déjà des individus qui euh ont euh
une interdiction de de manifester euh
qui euh euh qui est une décision cette
fois-ci de la justice judiciaire bon et
bien en fait le problème c'est que euh
euh il y a des difficultés
d'opérationnalisation de celle-ci et
vous vous retrouvez dans certains cas
avec des forces de l'ordre qui se
retrouvent euh avec un individu qui euh
est euh dans une situation de euh en
fait d'interdiction de manifester et qui
malgré tout euh euh se trouve présent
dans une manifestation et donc c'est à
partir de là que nous considérons qu'il
faut aller plus loin euh être plus
coercitif de de ce côté-là après la
question euh cette fois-ci de de
l'interdiction administrative c'est
encore un un autre volet mais là nous on
a surtout souhaité déjà euh faire en
sorte que euh comment dire euh les les
disposition du droit actuel deviennent
effective c'est-à-dire que euh elle elle
deviennent une réalité et que ce ne soit
pas en quelque sorte des mesures qui ne
seraient pas suivies des fait et puis
sur le la la première question je vais
laisser je vais laisser évidemment sur
rapporteur aussi vous donner des des
précision mais
évidemment libre à lui de de revenir
aussi sur sur la la 2e et la 3è ça va de
soi
oui sur les sur l'évaluation hein des
des des armes intermédiaires
alors regardons d'abord un peu
globalement ce que nous proposons euh
des observateurs
indépendants un contrôle externe plus
puissant à travers le Défenseur des
droits en particulier une présence
stabilisé mieux identifié de la part de
vos confrères issus de la presse ce sont
des éléments aussi
documentation
potentiel du déroulement des
manifestations de la réponse qui aura
été apportée par les forces de l'ordre
et puis ensuite une évaluation interne
par les forces de l'ordre elles-même
dans le cadre de la lopmie et de son
rapport annexe j'avais accepté en
particulier un amendement de notre
collègue
céciletermeer issu comme vous le savez
du Parti socialiste et qui souhaitait
que nous créons un conseil de
déontologie notamment sur la question du
schéma national de maintien de l'ordre
je pense que l'un de ces objectif
pourrait être de procéder à des
remontées d'informations sur l'usage des
moyens intermédies de façon le cas
échéant à adapter leur usage ou adapter
la dotation des forces de l'ordre en
moyens
intermédiaires je pense que
proposer un observateur indépendant un
contrôle externe au fond qui rejoint un
certain nombre de standard standards
européens notamment de l'Europe du Nord
je pense que ce sont pas des
propositions
anodines si nous voulons abaisser le
niveau de
conflictualité
sur autour des forces de l'ordre avec
des propos parfois
outranciers avec des attaques parfois
frontal et parfois à l'inverse indénis
de toute forme de difficultés il faut
que nous ayons tous les éléments de
documentation sur les forces
intermédiaires et de façon générale sur
l'ensemble du déroulé des manifestations
et il me semble que ce
cadre contrôle observateur journaliste
capacité d'évaluation interne peut
permettre d'y apporter une forme de
réponse et en tout cas ça ça me semble
véritablement essentiel sur ce sujet
d'objectiver le débat autour du maintien
de l'ordre en
Franceis de
laéé c'est des choses qui sont déjà dans
le la verion
tout à fait donc vous con qu' n pas
appliqué du tout si c'est le cas pour je
dis nous avons beaucoup de de retours si
tu permet je je réponds à la question
nous avons beaucoup de de retours
d'organisations syndicales qui disent
par exemple nous les sommations nos
manifestants ne les entendent pas VO ça
veut pas dire qu'elles sont pas elles
sont pas faites ça veut dire qu'elles ne
sont pas audibles le matériel utilisé
n'est pas à la hauteur pour que les
manifestants et parfois plusieurs
milliers de manifestants évidemment
parfois faut même plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de manifestants puissent
l'entendre de façon claire donc on a un
problème
euh de d'orientation des manifestants
pendant qu'il y a intervention des
forces de l'ordre en précortage il faut
que les manifestants soient mieux
informés alors il y a les officiers les
agents de liaison force de l'ordre
syndicat dans le rapport nous
préconisons qu'il soit deç systématisé
parfois mieux identifié la plupart du
temps ils sont là mais ça n'est pas
toujours le cas nous avons eu quelques
témoignages donc la question du lien
d'information permanent la question de
la capacité opérationnel donc à informer
les les services d'ordre des
organisations syndicales mais de façon
générale faire en sorte que Onon puisse
dot de moyens d'orientation
d'information en direct du déroulé ça
peut par exemple être des panneaux de
signalisation encore faut-il que ces
panneaux résistent à des g de Pierre par
exemple he ce sont des des éléments tout
à fait fait concret donc c'est pas
simple ça peut être des des technologie
sonores qui permet de faire en sorte
qu'on entendent mieux en plusieurs lieux
euh pour les manifestants mais là nous
avons un sujet qui est extrêmement
délicat qui est le moment de la
dispersion c'est là que les problèmes
sont sont provoqués systématiquement et
d'ailleurs nous rappelons dans le
rapport je fais une préconisation en ce
sens de faire en sorte que il y a
parfois de très grandes difficultés pour
nos concitoyens d'accéder au lieu de
rassemblement d'une manifestation des
filtrages des contrôles et cela est
parfois reproché d'ailleurs aux
préfectures concerné aux préfet
concernés et puis en revanche il est
extrêmement facile d'accéder au lieu
d'arrivver de la manifestation au lieu
de dispersion de future dispersion là
sans doute que il y a nécessité d'être
vigilant autant sur le lieu de
rassemblement que sur le lieu de
dispersion de la manifestation vous
voyez là ce sont des éléments très
concret très
opérationnel mais là évidemment je ne
dis pas que le schma national des
maintiens de l'ordre du maintien de
l'ordre n'est pas appliqué je dis
simplement les les moyens de
communication d'orientation
d'information en direction des
manifestants ne sont plus adaptés ne
sont pas adaptés à la montée en
puissance d'individus violent et qui
nécessite de mieux faire la partition
entre celles et ceux qui vont se
disperser parce que la manifestation se
termine et la phase de contestation de
revendication s'achève et celles et ceux
qui se greffent sur ce mouvement pour
faire tout à fait autre chose venir en
découdre avec l'intention de
déstabiliser les symboles de l'État au
risque d'attenter à la vie des forces de
l'ordre pour pour rebondir par rapport à
ce que vient de dire monsieur le
rapporteur lors des auditions ce qui
nous a aussi frappé c'est de constater
que alors c'est particulièrement le cas
quand quand on revient à sainteseline
c'est que que lorsque vous êtes
organisateur d'une manifestation et que
vous lancez un appel votre
responsabilité est engagée et elle est
engagée sur toutes les facettes et et et
on ce qui nous a le déplacement à
saintesine même je pense nous a nous a
tous
frappé parce que nous nous avons eu un
certain nombre de contacts notamment
aussi avec les élus locaux qui eux nous
ont clairement indiqué que la veille
même de cette manifestation du du du
samedi et bien il y avait un certain
nombre de de de de signes qui en tout
état de cause ne ne ne trompait pas qui
montrait des formes d'intentionnalité de
toute évidence violente et et qu'à
partir de là comment dire euh euh
l'ignier
est comment dire alors souhaite souhaite
c'est c'est c'est de l'inconscience ou
alors de de de la naïveté mais en tout
état de cause euh comment dire les les
élus locaux nous ont clairement indiqué
que en fait cette le le le mode
d'organisation allait rendre en fait la
la confrontation quasi inéluctable quoi
et donc comme le disait monsieur le
rapporteur ce qui nous a frappé c'est
que effectivement à
sainsine s'il y a eu contact avec les
forces de l'ordre c'est qu'il y avait
bien volonté de contact avec les forces
de l'ordre sinon ceci n'aurait n'aurait
pas eu eu lieu de toute évidence
oui je vous en prie bonjour de l'Agence
France
press avant qu'on arrive aux questions à
la fin de votre intervention vousz
évoquer votre souhait de modifier le
code de sécurité intérieure que ne soit
pas seulement les provocation desement
viol mais des provocations directes ou
indirect alors une nuance que P avou de
pas avoir
comprisité et ma deuxème question vous
avez donc évoqué une sur PPL une
proposition de voi dans les jours à
venir la question compliquée pour les
PPL comment évaluez-vous euh les chances
de cette PP d'être adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale alors avant
qu'elle soit adoptée il faut qu'elle
soit inscrite à l'ordre du jour donc si
vous voulez le le le le parcours
législatif à cet égard se se fera au
moins en deux étapes et puis comme vous
le savez après il faut que ça ça se ça
se poursuive je pense que comment dire
en en en tout état de cause euh si euh
enfin euh si si nous faisons cette
proposition c'est que nous considérons
que euh comment dire le les
recommandations euh mentionnées hein
dans le dans le dans dans le rapport et
qui euh qui donneent lieu à des
modifications à la fois du code de
sécurité intérieure et et du code pénal
euh sont des des recommandations qui qui
s'inscrivent euh dans dans le
prolongement de de du diagnostic quoi et
et donc euh on pense en tout état de
cause que cela devrait pouvoir relever
de de de l'inscription dans dans les
journées à minima d'initiative
parlementair hein et puis d'autre part
euh après et bien à nous de convaincre
euh une majorité de de de collègues de
de de la pertinence de tout cela mais ça
on va on va s'y employer je pense que
euh comment dire euh évidemment le les
les les sensi bilités politiqu sont sont
nombreuses au sein de l'assemblée hein
c'est tout à fait normal néanmoins ce
que j'ai pu noter c'est que au sein même
de de la commission il y a un certain
nombre de points sur lesquels nous
pensons qu'il est possible de dégager de
dégager des majorités quoi voilà alors
après encore une fois faut jamais
préjuger de de cela parce que dans le
dans le travail parlementaire ben c'est
aussi le le le le débat qui doit avoir
lieu sur la la proposition que que nous
allons que nous allons formuler mais moi
je reste je je reste raisonnablement
confiant à cette égard voilà ce que je
me permets de de de dire de dire à cet
égard mais je vais laisser aussi
monsieur le rapporteur s'exprimer à ce
sujet non mais elle a elle a toutes les
chances de de d'être inscrite et d'être
je l'espère adoptée parce qu'elle est
transpartisane parce que elle sera
transpartisane elle n'est pas encore
déposée parce que elle reflète le
travail de de 6 mois euh et qui qui
s'est voulu un vraiment je pense un
travail à la fois mettant à plat les
difficultés vous l'avez vu noccultant
aucune aucun sujet en particulier bon
donc nous aurons la toute la légitimité
pour pour plaider qu'elle soit un skite
et je ne doute pas un seul instant qu'
qu'elle le sera dans son agenda
législatif chargé ça je vous confirme
qu'elle ne sera pas étudié d'ici la fin
de l'année on se consacrera plus au
projet de loi sur l'immigration par
exemple euh sur la question de la
provocation directe indirecte il y a des
des stratégies de de j'allais dire de de
dissimulation de l'agissement violent
euh qui sont évidentes qui nous ont été
communiquées à plusieurs reprises
notamment par les services de
renseignement mais pas pas uniquement
donc il y a parfois pour les services de
l'État une grande difficulté à démontrer
que tel type de message au pluriel bien
sûr ce n'est pas un seul message qui a
été diffusé sur les réseaux sociaux ou
tel type de texte qui a pu être diffusé
sur un blog quand ça existe encore ou
sur des documents papiers font partie
d'une stratégie de confrontation et
d'agissement
violenton donc faute de laisser la
possibilité de documenter des
provocations
indirect les éléments qui sont
exigés dans la plupart des cas euh sont
quasiment d'avoir pris la photographie
de l'individu violent en train de jeter
une pierre sur l'agent de police par
exemple bon euh les soulèvements de la
terre prenons ce cas de figure les
soulèvements de la Terre ce ne sont pas
contrairement à ce qu'a dit récemment
Alain bougladubourg de LPO France de
gentils lanceurs d'alerte qui serait
tombé du
nid ce n'est pas tout à fait ça quand
même hein il
ils intègrent leur sang leur sein pardon
de véritables
théoriciens de la confrontation
violente qui qui qui la pense qui
ensuite souhaite la mettre à exécution
et qui repose d'ailleurs sur deux
piliers c'est la non dissociation
premier point la la non dissociation
c'est de faire en sorte que l'on puisse
agréger pour de mêmes causes et si
possible sur de même lieu c'était le cas
à sasine des manifestants de bonne
foi et des personnes qui sont venues là
pour en découvre la non dénonciation
dissociation et puis la non dénonciation
et ça nous l'avons vu à plusieurs
reprises la non déénonciation de la
violence ou de trouver des arguments
soudain très subtils pour expliquer ce
qui est de l'ordre de la violence et ce
qui n'en est pas nous avons vu par
exemple des individus qui parlent très
très facilement de la violence
symbolique du capitalisme il utilis bien
le mot violence la violence de l'État
symbolique par pas uniquement de ce
qu'il croit être le schéma nationale de
main al la violence symbolique voilà et
puis quand on leur dit mais les
violences qui sont commises à
saintsoline en marge d'un certain nombre
de manifestations vous en pensez quoi
attendez c'est pas de la violence non
non parce que le code pénal limite la
violence au violence au personne et pas
aux dégradation matérielles bon voyez
tout d'un coup il y a une sorte de
d'ppétit pour du juridisme là qui est
relativement étonnant alors que sur
beaucoup d'aspects ils sont prêts à
considérer que la légalité n'est pas
toujours l'objectif d'un manifestant et
que en particulier la la désobéissance
civile historiquement le démontrerait
bon nous n nous nous constatons un
glissement qui nous paraît extrêmement
dangereux des phénomènes de légitimation
des phénomènes aussi on sent un certain
nombre d'organisations syndicales
partisan littéralement dépassé par cette
radicalité et si dans le rapport
j'indique qu'il n'y a pas d'éco
terrorisme qu'il n'y a pas
d'écoterrorisme aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
une matérialité ce n'est pas pardon une
réalité matérialisée
l'écoterrorisme en revanche c'est un
risque réellement identifié y compris
par nos services de renseignement y
compris par la DGSI la cinte est très
simple
c'est que des individus progressivement
se détachent
d'organisation
radicales qui assume la confrontation
violente pour aller vers des démarches
très autonomes qui pourrai être le
passager acte terroriste ça ce sont des
risques que nous avons parfaitement
identifiés ce sont aujourd'hui des
causes de
vigilance totale de la part des services
de renseignement et des services de
l'État et donc il y a là un phénomène à
la fois de radicalité du débat politique
de légitimation de la conflictualité
permanente de non dénonciation de
stratégie de confrontation violente
voire d'actes de violence tout d'un coup
on considère que la violence elle est
limitée aux personnes enfin à samsoline
la violence en direction des forces de
l'ordre elle a été réelle et sur les
manifestations parisiennes aussi dans
les précortèges encore une fois je
distingue des cortèges voilà ce climat
là est extrêmement délétaire il est très
néfaste pour notre démocratie pour nos
institutions pour débat publ et si je
prends la question du schéma national de
maintien de l'ordre nous pensons donner
des éléments je les rappelle pas ici qui
permettrait probablement d'apaiser le
niveau de conflictualité sur l'analyse
du travail des forces de l'ordre qui est
difficile qui fait face à des individus
d'une violence absolument inouï qui
l'assume et qui parfois à travers le
débat politique se sentent d'une
certaine façon incité à
poursuivre simplement pour prolonger ce
que vient de dire monsieur le rapporteur
je voudrais mettre la focale sur quelque
chose qui nous a je pense fortement
étonné euh c'est euh on a pu mettre au
travers nos auditions en lumière le fait
que le concept même de désobéissance
civile euh comment dire euh relevé enfin
était aujourd'hui utilisé évidemment
dans une stratégie de de légitimation et
et en fait c'est il faut bien le dire
assez pervers puisque la désobéissance
civile quand vous prenez ses origines et
d'ailleurs elle a été revendiquée par
par par Gandy par par Martin Luther King
elle était sur des bases qui était
fondamentalement non violente et et en
fait aujourd'hui comme l'a dit monsieur
le rapporteur on on se retrouve dans une
situation où des personnes voire des
représentants d'organisation qui
développent euh en fait des des formes
violentes utiliseent ce concept pour
légitimer leur action alors que celle-ci
comporte une part de violence et alors
pour pour pour aller de dans dans dans
une forme de de sophistique on va
jusqu'à dire mais attendez il y a de on
ne peut pas parler de violence quand il
s'agit de bien il faut la limiter
évidemment uniquement aux personnes mais
en réalité les mêmes les mêmes qui
utilisent cet argument-là par ailleurs
n'hésite pas quand ça les arrange à
parler de violence symbolique et donc on
voit bien que en fait cette il y a une
volonté en réalité alors je ne sais pas
si elle est consciente pour tout le
monde mais en tout cas ce que nous avons
Notter c'est que la non euh dénonciation
de la violence et
l'utilisation de moyens rhtorique pour
en tout cas contribuer à la légitimité
la légitimer euh pose un problème à État
de droit quand vous ajoutez à cela
c'est-à-dire que en réalité après il
faut regarder c'est pour ça que le
rapport euh euh il y a évidemment un
risque énorme il faut bien le dire y
compris dans dans les les exégèes qui
pourront être faites du rapport il ne
faut pas décontextualiser les
recommandations ce qui est extrêmement
important c'est de bien considérer que
un ce rapport c'est un tout et que par
ailleurs les recommandations aussi sont
un tout et et donc à partir de là il
faut avoir conscience que ce qui est en
train de se passer c'est que on voit
bien que euh euh on on on on assiste à
une forme de comment dire de de
banalisation de de ce rapport à la
violence et lorsque l'on est évidemment
attaché à l'État de droit et au principe
républicain ça doit collectivement nous
nous interroger d'autant plus que on
voit apparaître des stratagènes pour
tout faire pour chercher à à à euh
comment dire à à échapper à cet État de
droit quoi et et donc comment dire la
vraie question qu'on peut se poser
derrière tout ça qu'est-ce qu'il y a
s'il y a plus d'État de droit euh enfin
hé là on sait ce que ça représente et
donc je je pense que là il faut et ça
nous le faisons je dirais avec comment
dire notre notre regard au bout de de de
6 mois de travail c'est de dire oui il y
a une une vraie question de fond qui est
ce rapport à à l'État de droit et et
chaque fois que l'on se met à côté de
l'État de droit ça doit nous interroger
si on est si on est en tout cas
République peut-être juste un un point
moi je vous je vous encourage à lire
parmi les nombreuses pages à lire du
tome 2 notamment la page 569 est
suivante concernant l'audition de Mégane
non merci et dans 3 minutes nous vous
laisserons parce que nous devons laisser
la salle euh elle est sidérante il y a
des armes par destination qui ont été
retrouvées sur place nous nous sommes
rendus nous avons vu ce que ça peut
donner voilà je pas vous faire une
description à la fois des boules de
pétanque des machettes des
haches des des morceaux reconstituer
pour y mettre des clous pour pouvoir les
lancer B voilà quand on interroge le le
l'un des
organisateurs de la manifestation de
saintsine tout cela est le fruit du
hasard et vraiment
c'est c'est dit de cette façon dans
l'audition tout ça est le fruit de ce
qu'il y a eu 24000 interprellations et
notamment fouille de véhicules et donc
il est normal qu'on y trouve des boules
de pétanque que voulez-vous il y a des
gens qui jouent à la pétanque il est
normal qu'on y trouve des haches et des
machettes parce qu'il y a des élagueurs
parce qu'il y a des bûcherons surtout à
la campagne il est normal que l'on y
trouve des battes de baseball parce que
c'est un sport quand même qui n'est pas
tout à fait confidentiel non mais voilà
c'était ça la réalité là vous voyez
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
stratégie de confrontation violente en
réalité à
non dénonciation et volonté de non
dissociation c'est que si on peut à la
fois mettre des personnes qui vont être
violentes et de façon c'est c'est une
stratégie c'est une tactique des
personnes qui sont non violentes et des
personnes qui sont de bonne foi alors on
peut gagner en visibilité alors on peut
gagner en force de frappe on peut gagner
aussi en phénomène de solidarisation
entre individus de bonne foi et des
personnes qui n'y sont pas là de bonne
fois qui sont là pour découdre et ça
c'est une stratégie totalement assumée
la même c'est théoricien au niau niveau
international il y a un auteur suédois
Malm qui a écrit absolument toute la
démarche qu'il faudrait suivre pour
atteindre cet objectif là c'est d'une
gravité extrême et là nous interpellons
évidemment les partis politiques quel
qu' soit le seul parti politique qui a
voté contre le rapport et sa publication
c'est le parti écologique les
écologistes c'est
significatif peut-être parce que ils
sentent des difficultés de
positionnement pas de ensemble de leur
base ni de l'ensemble de leurs
dirigeants nous avons interrogé marine
dandelier elle a été très claire sur le
rejet de la violence bon mais vous voyez
que là il y a des stratégies de
confrontation violente assumé qui posent
d'immenses problèmes et dont les risques
à venir sont une dérive vers des actes
plus violentss plus dangereux encore
nous allons avec monsieur le Président
devoir vous laisser pour laisser
place à celles et ceux qui doivent
prendre position dans cette place dans
quelques instants dans cette salle